hi I'm David Harbor I'm Winona Ryder and
we're doing the wire complete where are
you from where am i from
from White Plains in New York
Westchester County represent all right
do I have a brother no I have a sister
do you play a trombone Wow not present
tense oh yeah I did play trombone but I
mean again the verb plays like kind of
tricky because I held the trombone I
blew into it sounds came out like me
with the clarinet really yeah you played
the clarinet
were you awful at it yeah I was awful at
Charlie where does David Harbor live I
mean I think I give this general area on
the East Coast somewhere you'll find me
roaming David Harbor video game yeah
yeah David Arbor play some video games
huh I mean no no I wish they were that
on involving unfortunately they're more
immersive than pong yeah okay what when
Winona Ryder is the Google phrase so
what is Winona Ryder like awesome moving
on what please that's is the whole need
to say what's Winona Ryder's real name
this gets complicated
oh my god I don't even know this I'm
excited for this please my grandfather
at Ellis Island
it was Salomon Thompson but he was a kid
he didn't earn century had to say he was
with horowitz's with the name Barry Vito
oh got put in quarantine via curly oh
wow and so on my birth certificate it's
when
or Horowitz Wow can I ask another
follow-up question that Google may not
have asked I was in Minnesota recently
in many i/o and I was born in Winona is
that true yeah it is true okay it is
true so what my college roommate told me
was correct I showed up to college and
my roommate said I'm from Winona
Minnesota
it's where Winona Ryder that's true it's
also in the song route 66 really like
Steph Arizona
don't forget Winona but there's like
Winona Arizona
what is Winona Ryder's natural hair
color oh oh I think that's rude yeah I
was really blond as a kid but my natural
colors just chestnut dirty blonde
what is Winona Ryder's birthday it's an
awesome day where we celebrate the birth
of Winona Ryder what is your birthday
October 29 really Scorpio right before
Halloween yeah also I share it with
Fanny Brice and Kate Jackson all the
young kids are gonna love me price
really into the Fanny Brice reference um
what was Winona Ryder nominated for okay
I can answer this Winona Ryder was
nominated for an Academy Award for her
performance in Girl Interrupted yeah
Heather's women but and low in which way
you know many of you were not many
friend Academy more for those for the /
- twice oh my god what is David what age
is David Harper Oh Mary okay
what no you're not what do you do you
know how old I hope you have to do like
Jeffery like what is what is 44 years
old what did David Harbor win what did I
win yes what did I win and one apart on
stranger things but you also
one words we want a SAG ensemble award
all of us and then I want a Critics
Choice what is David harbors middle name
oh man do you know this it starts with a
K and it is the wasps pious name you've
ever heard Kenneth Kevin what's the
frequency Kenneth Harbor what is David
Harbor nominated for Oh how do we do you
have an hour please all sorts of things
yeah
no Academy Awards though and once more
went on to write of one I'm sick of the
David are everyone who is that's awesome
who does Winona Ryder look like who does
Winona Ryder look like I mean I think of
you as such an individual you probably
get hey you look like one right all
right flattering oh that's interesting
okay yeah I see a little bit of who are
Winona Ryder's parents Mike and Sandy
Mike and Cindy love Mike and Cindy who
does Winona Ryder play in the Simpsons
are you in the Simpsons I know nothing
about your career do you play yourself
no oh who do you play I play Lisa's
rival at school
Oh amazing who does like a diary I love
Edgar Allan Poe thing it was a long time
ago
are you at the popular girl like a god I
just beat her at that they make a better
diary I'm like wow that's a new one for
me too I'm excited about who did Winona
Ryder play in Star Trek I know the
answer this Spock's mother you were
human - my dad was yeah you even Spock's
got the ears you don't have them you
were what gave him his heart right
clearly I'm not his logic
who is Winona Ryder's boyfriend and
stranger things
Bob the brain Sean Astin may he rest in
is david harbor no he's none
what yeah watch season three of stranger
things what are the blimps that float
down on Thanksgiving Day Parade you know
the big Garfield blimp it's a little bit
like that that's what I base my
performance on it's so good I love fat
hopper I hope you do too
seriously he's my favorite British no no
I'm not British but my name is Bell the
weirdest way I think that's the thing
it's bother you it's fellow British was
David Harbor well that's the most
flattering thing anyone's ever googled
about me in my home so these are Google
god I wish we had a wish I was dedicated
that I wish I was yeah play may be yours
Johnny do the ancestry.com thing maybe
yeah I'll send my DNA to Amazon come
back all Mickelson that would be 78%
Mickelson is David Harbour playing the
thing good thing the thing is like a
character in comic books
oh and so they were there was all these
speculations that that was I was playing
I'm not allowed to say anything about
this particular film I'm doing but oh
but you're playing lots of things I play
lots of things you might in my
vocabulary a lot yeah it's a good thing
is David Harbor a nice guy as depends on
depends on a rider and this is blank
Winona Ryder how to pronounce Winona
Ryder
I mean Winona Ryder oh when did Winona
Ryder start acting
movies you're like what 13 turning 13
yeah well my dad took like oh and look
11 years old or something yeah this
property is condemned to play the little
sister well Willie I have the same
trajectory as you except I started at 37
I did a play at 37 and then when this
Winona Ryder grow but wait well I would
just say the Bay Area okay so not
Minnesota I was born there
I lived there for six months oh geez I
moved up the area pretty much yeah okay
how tall is Winona Ryder feet wait how
how tall is Winona Ryder feet I mean I
guess in feet I guess would because they
don't want to use the metric system so
how tall are you in feet well apparently
if I'm standing up straight I'm like
five it is funny sometimes I do catch
pictures of us on set together and you
look like the size of a real person and
I look like Gandalf in like the Lord of
things next to someone I mean I look
like an ogre like I look dog I'm 94
seriously is Winona Ryder his Winona
Ryder on social media hell no and you
shouldn't be either how David Harvey how
big like crazy it's just one word it's
to Teo oh he's too big stop with that
seriously stop I needed it okay how did
David Harbor become an actor like out of
the room perform cutting the theatrics
all right I was a colicky child so I was
scream
and crying so I was fostering that but
no one else five years old I did the
Wizard of Oz in kindergarten I had one
life look Henry there's a storm a-coming
up when you were in kindergarten no I
was like oh my god Charlie I played the
Tin Man you did yes I wanted to play
Dorothy but I didn't go oh the first
match okay something oh my god again
with this that's how tall is David
Harper in again people hate the metric
system that's what I'm learning from the
internet is like please enough with the
meters thing I'm six foot three six like
three and a half oh man to send up a
flare I'll come running that's crazy
is Winona Ryder married to Keanu Reeves
and the answer is absolutely yes much to
my chagrin chagrin why did Winona Ryder
cut her hair when did you cut your hair
I love your hair and the reality bites
movie that is worth short but that's
like you did that yourself
that's impressive I want you to cut my
hair know which one owned a ride or
character are you
we should note writer character are you
no no are you or me I'm the girl from
Heather's I'm Heather with the red
mallet Winona Ryder Kevin Bacon how many
degrees are you from Kevin Bacon oh my
god have you don't move I don't agree
yeah
I'm 0 degrees I've done a movie with
Kevin Lee oh who is David Herbert who
who does David Harbor look like again
it's my it's what you said like there's
no and it looks like you know but who is
David harbors father mr. Harbor who is
David Harbor into sighs I wore a suit
I'd like
three wise David Harbour Who's Afraid of
Virginia Woolf nominated for a Tony did
that play for like a year
I'm Broadway and in London yeah I pretty
amazing
hey thank you wire I hope you learned
something about
[Music]